plusieurs centaines de personnes se sont
rassemblées ici ce matin quelques pas du
siège de l'igpn la police des polices d
gilet jaune qui se sont rassemblés ici
tout simplement pour dénoncer les
violences policières dont ils sont
victimes depuis plus d'un an et demi et
le début du mouvement maintenant alors
aujourd'hui
pas de défilé dans les rues de la
capitale traditionnellement mais surtout
des prises de paroles des prises de
paroles de certains figurent de
certaines figures des gilet jaune mais
aussi et surtout des blessés et mutilés
nous en avons rencontré quelques-uns je
vous propose justement de les écouter et
je pense que le 14 juillet était un bon
jour pour pouvoir dénoncer et passer le
message qu'il faut qu'il faut
aujourd'hui rendre justice à l'ensemble
des victimes de violences policières
et si en ce qui concerne la partie
administrative qui engage proprement dit
les fonctionnaires quel que soit le
corps d'état que ce soit chez les
médecins
enfin du moins chez les hospitaliers ou
dans d'autres corps de métiers liés à la
fonction publique il ya une enquête
administrative syli à faute donc qu'ils
se gardent cette partie de l' enquête
pour pouvoir juger en termes de
professions leurs coéquipiers mes
sources
sur le volet de l'enquêté pénale
aujourd'hui il faudrait la donne est un
organisme à la fois neutre et impartiale
pour pouvoir mener une enquête a bien et
n'ont pu la laisser aux mains de la
police des êtres humains qui ont juste
demandé à pouvoir vivre dignement
avoir un logement décent pouvoir se
nourrir pouvoir travailler ces personnes
là ont été et bornier ont perdu l'usagé
d'une main d'un pied juste parce qu'ils
en demandent à pouvoir vivre et non pas
survivre voilà aujourd'hui l'état de la
france en 2020
voilà dans quel pays nous vivent ça a
changé beaucoup pas mal de choses parce
que bon le yatch été voir
je suis passé chez noctua liste parce
qu'on a trop fait en fait il s'enfonce
de plus en plus tellement que ça
commence bien détruit le visage quoi et
donc là je suis obligé de me refaire des
opérations du pathos eux et pour la
première aussi parce que tous les ans
pas tomber en fait c'est pas si c'est
pas maintenant on fait derrière yade et
où il ya des bosses je veux dire
heureusement c'est vrai d'ailleurs parce
que
alors monteur assez souvent mais la
dispersion donc s'est déroulée à midi
comme il était convenu avec les forces
de l'ordre une dispersion dans le calme
comme vous le voyez derrière moi mais
pour certains gilet jaune
la journée n'est pas terminée ils sont
nombreux à vouloir rejoindre maintenant
à la manifestation la marche des
soignants qui se déroule également dans
le centre de paris